prothèse de hanche stimulateur cardiaque
implants mammaires des milliers de
canadiens font confiance aux dispositifs
médicaux implantables
or la plupart de ces produits sont
approuvés par santé canada sans avoir
été testé de façon exhaustive
le produit est quasiment toujours
expérimental
les risques sont jamais parfaitement
définis au cours des dix dernières
années plus de 1400 canadiens sont morts
et plus de 14000 ont été blessées dans
des incidents en lien avec des
dispositifs médicaux dans plusieurs pays
du monde ces données là sont déjà
publiques mais pas au canada
donc on a dû négocier pendant plus de
deux ans afin d'obtenir une copie de
l'outil dont santé canada se sert pour
trouver des dispositifs qui
potentiellement pourrait poser des
risques
les journalistes valérie wallet et début
de mai khai de siby s'ils ont obtenu 160
mais le rapport d'incident est désirable
liés à des dispositifs médicaux
ça inclut des centaines d'appareils
médicaux liés à des centaines de
compagnies qui ont causé toutes sortes
de problèmes de santé et aussi de
problèmes techniques au canadien
malgré ces données impressionnantes on
estime qu environ 15 % seulement des
incidents et désirable sont rapportés
les chiffres sont très très bons les
conséquences de la sous déclaration des
incidents et désirable sont majeures
selon le bioéthicien dreams
c'est gigantesque parce que ça dit qu'
il ya des gens qui sont blessés ou qui
décède à cause d un plant est ce pas
documenté pour permettre aux citoyens
d'y voir clair les journalistes ont créé
une base de données qui peut maintenant
être consulté sur le site du radio
canada avec notre outil les gens vont
pouvoir chercher des dispositifs dont
ils se servent déjà ou que leur médecin
leur a offert est vraiment voir dans
combien de rapports d'incidents et ce
sont mentionnés incluant des rapports où
il ya eu des blessures ou encore des
morts
madeleine on comprend que cette immense
base de données ne serait que la pointe
de l'iceberg
une réaction de santé canada oui tout à
fait santé canada nous ont dit qu'ils
étaient tout à fait conscientes que le
problème de la sous déclaration est
chronique
ils entendent d'ici 2019 jusqu en fait
ce qu'ils veulent c'est rendre la
déclaration obligatoire pour les
hôpitaux
ça devrait aider parce que dans le
moment la déclaration est obligatoire
seulement pour les manufacturiers et
pour les importateurs et ces données
n'ont pas fini de livrer leurs secrets
ya d'autres révélations cette semaine à
venir jouer tout à fait on est plusieurs
journalistes qui avons travaillé sur le
dossier
demain on va commencer à vous parler des
implants mammaires on pensait qu'il y
avait plus de problème avec ça c'est pas
le cas
mardi on va parler des pompes à insuline
qui cause beaucoup de problèmes
mercredi on va vous parler d un plan qui
devient défectueux et qui sont très
difficiles à enlever
jeudi on va revenir sur un cancer causé
par les implants mammaires et à enquête
jeudi soir on a une heure pour vous sur
les implants mammaires
à ne pas manquer merci madeleine merci